let's go man let's really go let's do
dude let's do this pop i'm back with a
positive attitude
where were you where were you dick and a
tan
hawaii you know i don't look at any
tanner what so i'm in hawaii
how was white now did you see any tiger
shoes
you're of uh hispanic descent uh so um
yeah now uh i i truly believe in my
heart that you're samoan
i think you're a liar about being white
because you're not are we broadcasting
i'm sorry jen are we broadcasting in the
dark today
why is it so dark in here man it took
you in about 37 minutes
37 minutes ago it's dark oh it's a
haunted house it's not perfect but i
gotta
i gotta train three guys ah do that new
sign it's [ __ ] trash
i wanna apologize to everyone for the
podcast branded last week it's the
lowest ratings we've had
seven years and we had the you jinxed
the [ __ ] neon
sign dude that's her name how cool is
that thing yes i like it cat does work
man
okay we need a neon sign well done
that's not racist either chi chi chi chi
boom
because she was that that's the
well she's chosen out of metal cuz
right now i think okay that's not how
you do a neon sign
on the outside with glass so it would
sound like this
yeah you blow glass you blowing bro no
it sounds like this
it's how i blow glass did you see any
tiger sharks do you swim with [ __ ]
leatherback turtles what'd you do in
hawaii
besides hang out on the beach and get
bored i just hung out
you were there for five days i got a
text ready to come home for sure
five days is long enough you know what
i'm saying five days long that's how you
know you're living a good life
and you want to get back that's right if
i did i needed the vacation i'm bad at
taking them needed it feel a little
refreshed
missed you guys um sun fell into a giant
pool of koi fish on my watch okay
wifey was not happy with that didn't go
well took my eye away from
one like this yeah yeah right over
yeah into the water giant koi fish my
son
didn't eat alive yeah i'm like no i
couldn't lie
you start clubbing the koi yeah and
they're jumping on me and i'm fine i
always carry a small club when i'm
around
a pond of koi now dude you know my
favorite part was is there was a greeter
at uh
the four seasons that we stayed at on
hawaii beach and this guy
so everyone's you know native hawaiians
lived there
and though oh welcome to hawaii you know
how they talk and then there's a white
guy
then there's a white guy who goes oh
welcome to hawaii
hawaii yeah hawaii hawaii i went
oh he's a white guy born and raised in
hawaii that's cool man good for him
dad's probably
white mom [ __ ] hawaiian that's
fantastic
two days go by oh hey bra hey bro you
check out the waves out there bro hey
bae
why why no hawaii i'm like all right
he's really playing up that accent
that's strange
another day goes by he's the reason my
son fell into the [ __ ] koi fish she
was
shut my [ __ ] air off about the fights
yeah and he goes you know the fire bra
in the hawaii they're scrapping bro they
[ __ ] scrap bro they scrap bro oh hey
man
i was getting on my own where are you
from he was jersey
oh no you [ __ ] chameleon
now if you go to jamaica you'll see
chinese ethnic chinese people
and white people who've grown up in
jamaica and they'll they'll talk like
this you know
all the chinese and all the white people
who grew up in jamaica speak
exactly like this and it's real because
that's the way they grow but it's not
real is it no because you're making the
real one
unrest in jamaica so there's no way you
can
i see it jamaican girls welcome to the
beach man i would turn
right around and get on a plane how
about this me i'm with my girl
in jamaica i'm a young man i'm hanging
out i'm talking this dude
this other guy comes up and goes where
are you from man i go uh you know me i'm
a chameleon i can i can
you know i graduate adapting yeah i go
um
i'm from new york originally he goes you
man you move like a jamaican
ask him what i said and the guy goes
yeah man you move like a jamaican by the
way you move oh they're finessing you
i i was like they're 100 percent
pronouncing you how about this so i go
hey man so you know me i'm like you play
guards mom
i do i kind of do move like can i do
move like
because for me i move i'm moving
when you see underland and food
all the food i eat has stamina food you
know that every time
you break down this super stamina means
you can [ __ ] all day
super stamina under the sea and where
you can
some goat curry some curry goat okay
i'll give you guys some
give us some stamina did you tell them
hey boys
hey boys let's foot race now let's photo
racer down the beach man
let's race on foot down the beach man
because you guys are fast in jamaica
sprinting sprinting at the national
sport and then track is the nationalism
just generalized
hey man you know who's saying batman no
it's a giant i know everyone here is
fast
and everyone here i would dick all the
way down to their ankles hey man you
guys got
dicks the size of guns no man i know i
didn't care
man you've seen you're seeing jamaican
sled team what was that movie
jamaican cool running smart
cool runnings one foot of money two for
the show
yeah ah star dude that was a great movie
yeah one of the one of the best one of
the best man
cool the real runners the one guys from
new jack city man
yeah oh there's there's john kennywood
they were finessing you john candy died
man
you fat man younger 10 years younger
than me when he died
two more fat man too fat too far
tomorrow you're too fat
who else died i'll soon come back you
know oh
the lefty from kentucky quarterback
passed away
yeah you know what i'm talking about big
dr
laurence the lefty from the what
happened hefty the hefty lefty
what happened excuse me what happened to
him oh this heart went
i'm out that's a really fat guy that we
talked about a while back
yeah do we know what he passed away from
i'm pretty sure his heart was just like
i
just can't do this anymore jerry
lawrence nope definitely not him
laurence lorenz he was a real heavy guy
played indoor
arena l-o-r not lawrence lorette
oh laurence
there it is jared lorenz lorenzen
vicky
[Music]
six four three and 15 pounds um
yeah that's a big boy did they say how
he went away
but he he was on e60 and they're talking
about his health and there you know he
had a son
and he was like i gotta get in shape for
my son so it's kind of a sad story
kidney failure yeah did what was wrong
with his kidney
it failed i was just kidding
died at 38. the [ __ ] dude big men
big men break down i tell you that all
the time i don't think i feel like
you're going to live a long time
from an acute infection complicated by
heart and kidney problems
yeah which would be due to his weight
huh yeah probably got to get my weight
got to get my weight on track i ate just
two pieces of small bread
uh at 12 30 last night and i'm i'm so
[ __ ] up i can't eat before i go to bed
right now wait a second
dude dude i'll tell you what man i was
at the right down by the beach
in hawaii i was probably the most out of
shape dad what the dads there were
shreds is that true
the dads were shredded i felt like a fat
pig i felt like adele i felt like adele
at the beach
no yeah dude like the male adele i was
like and i can mail someone a dollar
yeah i looked at my girl what you know
what about the voice that's it as soon
as we had done this
i'm getting on a serious diet diet
started today you tried give me
i tried to get you to have no one bite
well well they had those chocolate chip
cookies
hold on you haven't had those chocolate
chip cookies from across the street the
best you ever have well dude they have
like a gooey thing
stupid sometimes you look at chocolate
chip cookies then you go oh that will
change my life
it makes my mouth the chocolate is so
stupid and i went i go
and i looked at you and i go i was about
to say do you want it and you go i can't
do it
dude you're an indian you're an enabler
you want me to be thick
you want me to be thick yeah i had a
nice kale salad with salmon
okay some cauliflower that's [ __ ]
and a bunch of coffee today
dude you know what i uh i i had too much
coffee oh i
never thought oh they're nice oh that's
a
chinese place yeah um taiwan taiwanese
don't go changing don't do that again uh
sorry um
you know what's interesting though in uh
where i stayed in hawaii
they had those automatically pronounced
hawaii yeah
[Music]
uh automatic toilets that the like the
bidet
have you used one of those i have one
have you got one at the crib don't use
them anymore because
don't use it because it doesn't quite
get your anus the proper way
you know why you don't have the right
positioning because you can move the
pressure and the power
that thing was blowing my entire lower
undercarriage the tape
to the balls to the booty yeah
everything clean me all out dude then
it's like then you just take a napkin
boom in and out i believe it was
i believe in in cleaning your [ __ ] so
all of us are walking around i've seen
brian a dirty wife you were probably 47
at the time
i've seen brian jump on top of a sink
like a gargoyle
and wash his [ __ ] out in a restaurant
sink that'll happen every time my ass
my hole is my whistle is clean piping
clean dude my my
boys you could not to be gross but you
could eat off my whistle at all times
yeah i mean if i was a gay man you'd
want your [ __ ] like brian kevin's
right
the thing is and don't be surprised
nothing berry brown
that thing is very brown right okay i'm
gonna blanch it and then his balls are
gonna be red hot hanging low that's true
they're red hot hang low red hot wrinkly
as
as a sharp uh forehead yeah
brendan just said well it's the most
offensive thing i've ever heard yeah
cat be honest i mean let's
go ahead and stay on the safe side yeah
just in case
yeah these are trying times all right
we'll do everything that you guys want
to do
it was a good reference though but he
did like in me bent over with my balls
hanging over to something
yeah and it was that's something you're
not allowed to okay
all right okay okay sorry guess what we
have
power of editing and that means your
career is not over yet
thanks dude yeah uh speaking of uh being
over the
women's olympic team won the
championship the women's uh world cup
team
yes did you uh your brother told me that
the women's world cup team
as awesome as they are wba high school
all-star team they lost
five nothing to a 15 and under men's
national
boys team oh enough i heard it's 15
nothing oh well
i don't know either way they beat the
brakes off them but the women's defense
they go
they go well we weren't we weren't
really playing they were dead stairs
and here's my thing to that um
let's say let's say lebron james played
a high schooler
and the high school went up five nothing
and they were playing at 15.
the score would be 15 to five because
lebron like oh this kid seriously i'm
gonna play now
i'm never gonna beat him
right yeah i think they're i think it's
five to two dallas academy boys
dallas academy's boys there they are
i mean that that makes sense they're
boys and they're they're really good and
they're 15 year olds does it make sense
but does it brian i mean men are
stronger and faster and better athletes
in these kinds of sports than women are
or stronger and faster stronger yeah and
that's a fact
you know what to to defend though the
ladies here
is uh some people think it's more pure
game because they can't rely off their
athleticism so there's more passing more
technique sure than the men's game i
love lessons
i love women's fighting i i i think it's
just to me in a lot of ways just as
exciting as men's fighting
yeah i'm a [ __ ] but yeah ufc we have to
edit that aren't we god
doing it no uh you wanna live you can't
even live
anymore dude no i like this new app the
espn one app i actually like the app
i like watching this plus i like all
these apps now it's easier to watch [ __ ]
i think
once you download it do you watch your
phone i did no i watched it on
i watched it uh on my tv i watched oh
you downloaded it
yeah yeah it did if you could i didn't
have any problems with this one either i
i got on my phone and then married it to
the tv in the hotel and watched it
yeah yeah um
what brian what do you think of the
fights there right
just all right no they were great what'd
you think dude let's get your thoughts
guys did an hour and a half long podcast
on it
uh i mean i think that uh i i
i i i love you the main ones bro i love
jorge masbidal
i think i think that in the ufc when you
have guys like jorge mas vidal who
live eat and breathe fighting they're
just they're such
fighters that there's no room for
anything other than that you're going to
be competing against
like he just he just lifts the level up
i i would imagine as a fighter and you
go
well i don't have if i don't have that
fire i got to get the [ __ ] out of here
well because i'm going to be hold on
you're confusing people because
you're saying this because we were
talking about luke rockhold outside of
this
so you're jumping right into that b
because ben askren he sleeps and
breathes fighting
he just got knocked out yeah the
nationals absolutely kill it so there
doesn't make sense
what do you say no you're talking about
yawning i was just talking about i was
just talking about
jorge marvel and how he's nick diaz 2.0
to me as far as just a straight-up
fighter and that's it yeah i mean just
unbelievable i mean it's so personal to
him but he's so
he's so [ __ ] good best knockout ever
i think
yeah crazy i don't like seeing that i
don't like seeing it guys
i hate seeing that i thought they have
to take them out on a stretcher they
they almost should have i i just hate
seeing it
uh and what i what i think is
interesting is that the ufc
is such a an unforgiving you know i i
wonder i wonder
i wonder now ben askren's such an
amazing wrestler and he was just
wrestling
and 19-0 used his wrestling i want to
see and i think the same thing was about
to happen
with robbie lawler um and i think if
they fight again
i would i would put my money on robbie
lawler interesting yeah so
so again ben askren as great as he is
and he's great
and a hell of an athlete i i do think
that he's primarily a wrestler and i do
think that that's a liability against
the higher echelon guys in the ufc like
jorge monster yeah it's like i'm not
easy
i'm not even talking yeah and i'm not
but i think of him in the flying knees
kind of
you know see ya but i think if him and
jorge fought a hundred times you get a
different result every time
that's fair that i i i that's fair
i think ben can beat anybody in the
world because he couldn't get caught
with a
flying knee crazy yeah i beat everybody
yeah i know what he does with
world champs in the training room
destroys him yeah yeah
i mean his high levels of get anthony
pettis is like i've never embarrassed
myself
like that trying tons of guys what's
hilarious to me is just how
just there's nothing like fighting man
because before this ben askren
really was the most famous guy in this
card if you look at the polls everyone's
you know saying they would rather watch
ben asking than jon jones amanda nunez
jorge mazwidal
everyone luke rockhold he's very likable
uh
no he's more of a like he trolls right
so people love to hate him
so there's that and then he was that you
know he wins this
he gets a title shot and then now it's
like should he retire is it over
because he's lost one fight from a
flying knee in basically two seconds
i do i do want him to take a year off
for his head
i mean he's seeing that yeah i know it
isn't but i i think he should
six months um amanda nunez the best
ever by far the best ever destroyed
holly [ __ ] crazy
how good she is what do you think of jon
jones thiago i think uh
i think jon jones like people well
thiago's
knee gave out stuff a hundred percent
sure jon jones won anyway
and jon jones wins and jon jones is the
best and
you i thought i thought i thought this
was the first fight literally i
i mean the guster one gets in so good i
really i was like that makes sense
because it's that good
this is the first time i went oh john's
definitely beatable if he gets it comes
across the right guy he's definitely
beatable
he's getting hit so so i didn't see him
get hit so
i didn't see him get so the way that guy
was his chin was tested the way that guy
thiago santos hits
is is you can he just sits down and
starts throwing he's he's really really
powerful
and i see why he's knocked so many
people out i did
it jon jones he got his he did he
talked about his cage i didn't see him i
have guys who were caged and like oh no
they was
it shows you how great of a chin john
has because he was getting blasted
when he's backing up and getting hit
yeah but usually were they grazing blows
right
he got hit bro he got hit i really
didn't but there was always something in
the way there was always a little bit of
glove there's always a little bit about
i thought it was one the first time too
john's defense looked a little suspect
it was the first time i went oh he's
beatable if you want to i
i can kind of see why john's hesitant to
go to heavyweight
uh really because because guys can sit
there and let's fight over if it's
francis and got it
oh yeah and one's over yeah yeah
yeah you can't does that batching up
that he's doing because he's so much
bigger than one right
what level playing feeling is the
heavyweight hmm
the first time i went oh that's what
yeah that makes sense right
i think it's a because he knows like
that he might get hit there in this game
over at heavyweight
and b he needs dana white to back up the
the brink trucks to use
crystalia's reference he needs to bring
bring trucks backed up to go to
heavyweight
big time yeah well because he's probably
he's also remembering
230 like when he walks around i don't
think he's more than that
uh he can be but he's like 227 230.
these guys are two treasure five
shredded yeah but these guys are in
ghana is 260
cutting into 265 okay so that's a much
bigger man
but if it goes past the first round and
got france to be in trouble
john can grind and take you down
remember you can take francis down like
that
take him down john will do well at
heaven i still think you'll be having a
champ but
there's a reason why he's not jumping at
the opportunity he'd have his hands full
with [ __ ] uh stipe
jose and right i mean
yeah i mean if he if you get hit like
that it could be a problem
there's also you know also him fighting
dc at heavyweight different animal too
yeah
dc hits a little harder dc was winning
those early rounds he got head kicked
you know
but that was the first time i went oh
okay he he's actually
beatable when i didn't think he was even
beatable
you didn't think he was i don't think
anyone beat john ever right but after an
hour
john had to be carried out of the cage
you know that he had to be carried out
what was it was it leg kicks
the one thing is that he's got those
tiny skinny legs
and i've always wondered and i was going
to ask you this actually i've always
wondered
why you wouldn't just hack at that front
leg over and over again
because you could blast in the face or
what should you blast in the face
plus thiago is a smaller fighter but and
then also for
light kicks you're going to encounter
you have to throw something ahead of it
right yeah one two two
one two kick until you get your time and
then get knocked out or taken down too
right well thiago's haven't successfully
blown its knee
he was having successfully blown a split
decision i have a problem with split
decision
i don't know what's next for john let me
look at the light heavyweight rankings
chin
i don't even know yawn knocked out luke
i really don't see that santos destroyed
yawn
um you see what happens with dc stipe
dominic reyes probably your next best
bet
how tall is reyes athletic kid played
football
good footwork he's been fighting how
long not that long
yeah my my money is
i'm always on johnny oh yeah john's
gonna be a heavy favorite in
every fight yeah besides dc at heaven he
just finds a way to win man he just wins
you know people seem to get a little bit
closer but they don't
i was surprised he didn't take uh 6'4
jesus big kid
really athletic i'm surprised he didn't
take
santos down that was a weird fight weird
fight
it's entertaining and then your boy luke
yeah thoughts
my thoughts you know last week yeah i
was with him last week and
um i just first of all i hope his jaw
gets better
and bro yeah i hate seeing that and
i i i don't want to speak for him and i
don't i don't want to say
anything you know i i my feeling is that
he seemed a bit
um
you put on me what did i tell you when
you text me about the fight yeah what
are you doing you you you've i've
already gone over to be so
uh yeah he kind of
wants out maybe he's he's not it's not
even that he like he's
scared and nothing like that and
remember luke is a hall of famer he's
had a great career two-time world
champion
when i when you and i are texting i went
if i had to bet i'd say
he doesn't want it as bad as these other
guys his other
other job has a lot of other options
luke has a great career after this
but everyone wants to paint this this
isn't a sad story this is a successful
story luke's had a phenomenal career
two-time world champion
super famous in the ufc dime piece yeah
ralph lauren model
he has other options and by the way this
isn't sad yeah
but also every name any fighter that you
like
any fighter that you like who sticks
around long enough
ends up face down any fighter and part
of anyone and
part of it also you can say well
sometimes people grow out of this
sometimes there's there is that i think
that what happened with you and and i
think with luke and
sometimes you've been doing this so long
you grow out of it uh how long does luke
go down to when it was his first fight
he started fighting 2007.
i mean that's a long [ __ ] time 12
years
12 years 12 years of this grind i mean
any idea
how long no i've got lighting actually
no i don't but i'll tell you something
that kind of training
all the time you get to the point where
you're like i think i've outgrown this i
think i want to do something else
if you don't have the same fire as jorge
mas
his legs messed up he has issues with
his his foot
you know it's it's it's a constant
you're gonna grant and again
luke's all sure fire hall of famer
phenomenal
two-time world champion fought the best
beat the best
lost some of the best great fighter this
is not a sad story
for someone to go well he might not be
into it because he has
a ralph lauren modeling contract is a
successful story is that successful
because you know what you know who else
we're talking about retiring is david
sanchez what's he gonna do
well he doesn't look like luke rockhold
no
there's no modeling contract oh diego
sanchez
hold on hey ralph lauren ain't hiring
diego
sanchez they'd hire maya's ass either oh
they sure as [ __ ] hiring diego
sanchez now you know that i love
i love diego sanchez you know i love him
and you know the other the who does that
somebody thought i had to take a moment
just to just to acknowledge him and
everything else he's awesome he's the
best
he's awesome he's the best not a model
i'm not a mom now i was hoping that his
new cornerman guru
was going to be helpful here that guy's
the best
his corner man might be the best i think
i'm thinking about hiring him myself
well
he seems he had his hood on do you have
any thoughts on that guy
well you look at one video and you think
watch out
let me see this i sent you this video
brian before the fight i went you want a
piece of dia sanchez's coach
oh dude he seems to be what's up bro
this is the same grab ass you do at the
gym up the street dude he seems to be
totally hold on look at this dude look
at the movement he's elusive
look at the movement listen i love the
sound
very elusive right now look at this
dude he's what's up bro so well what's
up bro
no look what's up now here comes an
elbow for your ass
what what the [ __ ] i'm i keep coming and
he just keeps not being there yeah look
good luck
i hate fighting guys like this because
they're literally invisible dude good
luck and then when she starts throwing
elbows
once you get your distance this is
literally invisible technique
i don't even know what the [ __ ] every
time every time the bag comes yeah
it's not there look at it every time
what the [ __ ] dude i didn't even see
that elbow
exactly the [ __ ] dude i dude here comes
it yeah
okay come on you can't do it again what
the [ __ ] dude
dude this guy he said that damn dude i
knew that video
that was five unanswered elbows i knew
that video would infuriate you
that's why i sent it to you i answered
said brian i think i found your coach
that that's some voodoo [ __ ] and i'm
impressed movement coaches were the
crazed for a second
that is some impressive [ __ ] i'll tell
you what though if there's nothing
doesn't need a corner sanchez yeah yeah
go here
also dale was gonna lose that fight
whether he had this guy in this corner
[ __ ]
yeah michael cheers is he's one of those
dudes who just keeps getting better and
better michael j
he's great at welterweight man real
threat real threat right where'd you
watch the fight that brian i was in my
home
i was in my home had some people over
and the fight that is crib drank a
little too much wine not gonna lie would
you do for the fourth
and had some people over who got drunk
and i have a problem with drunk
i don't like when people get drunk
people i know
people who get drunk here's the thing i
bet i know i deal with drunk
when i'm on the road and uh there's
nothing i need more there's nothing i
hate more than drunk
i don't know what it is you know me i
love everybody i know me
i love everybody right we don't get
drunk no well i get a little bit but
when i gotta deal with a drunken
drunk like that who's just loud and
obnoxious women men
i i'm allergic to it i've been dealing
with it for so long on the road
there's no yeah it's a trigger for me
it's on my breast right two
this girl and a couple in the front row
hammered talking the entire time
smashed and i just went listen guys you
gotta shut up everyone starts clapping
like thank god you said some moment
i'm sure you're hilarious these people
paid money to see me do stand up
i'll give you five minutes when i'm done
since you want to talk so much i'll give
both you five minutes we'll see how it
goes
but please quit talking nothing drives
me god it's nuts to me
yeah it drives me crazy those people got
hammered yeah
out there people that love you so much
too sometimes people will like well yeah
they get drunk and they're just like
you're gay repeat your jokes they are
gay though oh my god
they get drunk gay yeah they get drunk
like i i when i
get drunk i get a little about five
percent gayer yeah
like five percent ten or whatever it
does not five or fifty or 50.
which means i'm full-blown gay yeah you
made a pass
what harvey milk um cat what'd you do
for the fourth
um i actually ended up going home i took
my brother and my baby cousin go see
spider-man which is cool
was it good it was good everyone says
the new spider-man's like the best
it was good it was damn i guess comic
book it was
i don't i think it was one of my
favorite uh marvel movies people love it
it's good
the spider-man movies have been killing
it this spider-verse
spider-wish was so spider-verse wasn't
me i didn't see it you still didn't see
it you gotta take your son well
it's too late just watch it gun uh apple
with your son it's great
yeah chin what'd you do for the fourth i
went fishing
the morning
by yourself no fishing for guys what
what like
what did you catch uh i didn't i caught
one bass it was terrible it's nine hours
buy back got one
you caught one bass but bass is good
fishing it wasn't legal size so you can
keep it he was tiny yeah well not tiny
but it has to be 14 inches that's all
you caught after nine hours and i got
everyone got sick well most of us got
sick why you were you drinking
no it's just the nine hours on a boat on
july 4th yes in the morning
it was so crowded it sucked it was it
was probably one of the worst fishing
trips what were you thinking dude i
don't know
and then what'd you do for the night of
the fourth so the fishing trip ruined
everything
what is that i was so tired when i got
home i
took a nap i woke up at midnight so i
missed my friend's party i missed
everything oh you're supposed to see
your friend's party and fill up
hot dogs with my family that was it for
like an hour and then knocked out you
see any fireworks
no dude hawaii did it right yeah i
thought
i sat down in the finale fireworks yeah
i was with my kids and
it was only cool my son loved it he's
never seen him before oh he's never seen
him
he's like oh that's so cool and when i
did it for you because you did this i
went i did it
now when you have a kid when you have a
kid what's crazy is that you'll watch
your kid's face not the fireworks oh
yeah i don't know
you'll watch your kid's face as he's
watching the fireworks because like i
watch my son
when he watches a movie yeah he giggles
and laughs he's so
invested you'd rather watch you watch
his face dude i played two hours
which i i mean i can time went by we
were uh
scuba divers looking for treasure in the
ocean two hours of that [ __ ]
it i didn't feel like well me and him
pretend we were scuba divers
crawling the ocean floor and we're
grabbing seashells oh wow
two hours of that every morning it's a
lot that's fun though yeah it's really
fun
i would i would uh snorkel with my
daughter and she was afraid of more eels
and
sharks makes sense yeah she'd basically
be swimming on top of me
and it's fun yeah i could do it all day
now do you have you ever scuba diving
no so i scuba dived into tahiti because
i'm sort of dude
i'm certified go back dude look come on
bro come on i love them i love them i
i'm obsessed
cute i'm certified in scuba and i was
scuba diving would you certify that i
got school certified when i was
you know 14. we're at the country though
yes the uh
in massachusetts okay i'm sorry in uh in
uh
new hampshire in lake winnipesaukee well
uh
okay yeah oh straight up because before
he said new england
that's where i was in new hampshire
that's new england all right now take it
easy well
because you're going you gave me
basically three different places now
there are three different locations
because the reason i'm kind of like the
reason i'm talking a lot
fast and stuff yeah change that sounds
like you're lying because i'm no longer
certified
but i was certified my certification
means nothing now by certification you
mean
you were snorkel certified no i was i
was a i can
scuba dive and mainly what it is is that
you could take my mask off
like when i'm 30 feet down and i don't
panic yeah you figure out what happens
very common or pressure now screwdriving
is dangerous
it's dangerous as [ __ ] athletes you know
it's in their contract can't scuba dive
because you stay down there long enough
you get nitrous
oxide poisoning and then you take out
your regular and try to give it to the
fish they can breathe and then
you die a ton of things can go wrong a
lot of things in hawaii
we were asking what to do and like oh
this sounded so dangerous that's pros
and cons
like we have the submarine right we have
this little submarine where we take
people down yeah and you're in
the ocean and we'll see what coral life
is down there
well no where's the submarine is it the
u.s
navy submarine no oh no it's a oh no
it's a submarine a guy made
well no i can't do that with my family
and go [ __ ]
60 leagues under the sea for a hundred
dollars
not your way to die however so so tahiti
is the safest ocean they'll always tell
you
sharks there's nothing there really no
jellyfish that can kill you
there is one thing see the problem is
people can tell you one thing and ruin
everything
the only problem in tahiti oh i know the
rock fish yes
the [ __ ] rock fish you stay on this
rock fish story you step on that
[ __ ] and
game over horrible and there's something
i mean came home
it looks like a rock that's a fish yeah
it sounds exactly right i'm like i don't
want you to do it
bring up a rock fish or a stone don't
just stone fish stone fish yeah
and you don't see them and i saw them
when i was scuba diving because the guy
pointed out i was like
only because you pointed right at us did
you see all the people getting [ __ ] up
by stingrays
now look at that thing i have to be hard
not to step on of course it's hard not
to step on that don't look too bad it
looks like it's
so painful when you step on it oh well
look at that person's fat ass foot the
second picture in australia man survives
that again looks like it's the pain
apparently the pain is the foot just
looks like that cat no one's asking for
a picture of my
wow that's sea urchin oh yeah
oh how about uh like over by the rocks
where we're
we're a little like jesus christ again
that looks like my foot
um now you can die from it yeah then my
foot looks identical
so i have a fat foot um so there are
like rocks with little crabs and my son
like love like seeing the crabs and this
mom was over there had the cutest
daughter
the mom goes ooh look it's a sea anemone
you touch them they
they go in and they go i don't see any
of those i look against the sea urchin
she's going oh we can touch on whoa
don't don't touch that she's why i went
they're they don't you're thinking of a
cnn that holds in like me
touch the sierra no the sea urchin those
are spikes now you don't want your
daughter touching that
no no you stupid i i think i was i was
you said you called her i think i was in
i was in santa barbara and the woman
said be careful there's a
blue octopus the ones that are really
poisonous
i don't know if that's an octopus the
jellyfish the the what is the blue
there's the box fish blue build octopus
or something like that
oh yeah that one they're supposed to be
super insanely painful they look sweet
can you see where they're from because
i think women's oh they're from the
ocean we saw a blue ringed octopus
around here so be careful
that's it does that say what it's like
to die from a blue ring octopus
they're cool man you know what i don't
eat calamari anymore
i love octopus so much i stopped eating
calamari those are squid no i'm just
saying
yeah i don't eat the squid though yeah
but but there's also octopus
octopus are really smart and i stopped
eating octopus because i saw eat some
but yeah you're right
if it's really good an italian
restaurant i will but no mediterranean
bro
when they grill it i know i lived in
greece
they would beat it against the rocks to
make it tender then they grow out i felt
terrible
[ __ ] my stomach loved it bro grease
the way they cook
lamb and they would take a goddamn
octopus you
it'll knock you out dude my [ __ ] diet
is so [ __ ] different brian don't even
come at me you
what do you mean why are you trying to
lose weight how much weight are you
trying to lose you're always on a diet
what that's your girl bro let's be thick
what ass my girl yeah [ __ ] she says
about my weight
dude what yeah i'm a thicky 3c
thick bro i was reading this thing uh
this uh
extensive study that some smart people
did
over 3000 people and they're basing off
of
protein like foods that they ate and the
worst you can eat is steak
as far as the foods go eating a lot of
steak should be once a month it says
fish and chicken we know this right fish
and chicken mainly if you're gonna eat
why not yeah why because the steak's so
heavy in the red
meat it showed like what it does if you
eat it every week
what it does your body imagine if you're
a real athlete though like rogan eats
red meat constantly every day argentina
i don't think it's good eat that much
red they say it's hard for your body to
digest
probably tougher to break around in
nigeria for certain parts of the world
they eat meat every day
but you know who lives well they eat me
i'm not saying meat you eat chicken fish
no they eat them but if you red meat
every night
i can't deal with it i can't i can't
they're just saying overall
in the grand scheme you want me to wake
up at four in the morning
covered in sweat like overheated give me
a young boy
what what no that too but no
but no sweating no no sweating yeah
give me a steak two glasses of wine at
eight nine o'clock at night
i will be up at four like i'm over here
really
oh i can't do it oh you know what's fun
what i live at where it's 110 degrees
oh my sea's out sir that's a good time
now that that you know when i was in the
right
heat yes that's how i slept last night
it's kind of warm in these rhinos yeah
dude sweaty i i do
i can sleep in the cold can't sleep in
the hot i'm going off very little sleep
guys
the rhinoceros that's me right there
sleeping oh my god
it's getting warm in these rhinos oh my
god look at him
dude [ __ ] so [ __ ] funny so funny
that's one of the greatest i don't give
a [ __ ] what anybody says
that movie's so genius i think everyone
loves that movie b
oh my god look at that dude how about uh
at the improv the other night
[ __ ] your boy i didn't know you and
him know each other right tattooey
um pat and i was pat and oswald that's
my boy not the two voice of the two
hadn't wrote on mad tv i've known i
didn't know that
you guys were like chum in the night
yeah it's my boy i love pat and he's
been coming on the show yes he is well
pat and tom green and tom coming on the
show rob schneider
want to come on the show yep um but you
got pat oswald who killed it doing
stand-up that was a fun show is patton
you me adam corolla yeah kate quigley
weird weird crowd
a little weird improv is always hit or
miss didn't it a little bit different
not for me i did very well that night
i'm very very good
it might went well for me as well i saw
that one well for you too
but anyway um yeah but but it was fun
yeah i forgot you and pat know each
other because he was a writer on mad tv
yeah he's a great pattern he's
highlighted was one of the specials i've
met
he's one of the first dudes i met when
he was writing stan writing sketches
where
i was like i remember marveling at how
good he was i was like you're
so [ __ ] he's so nice too oh he's the
nicest person
ever and then we saw tom green and i
dude i wanted to call you out when he
goes
what are you guys doing for the fourth
i'm having a party at my house he went
dude i might show up on
no he's not he's absolutely not i know i
was going to and then i was like no you
know i can't because i don't know
my kids you're not going to do that my
kids i got to watch if you've got a
family can't go anywhere on the 4th
what are you talking about no you can't
i was going to give you an out you know
no no i should have we got to text him i
said i can't i love tom green
he's great he's so funny man that's
great he's [ __ ] great
should we do some current events man
current offense buddy sure have you guys
do you guys ever watch king of queens
sure i king of queens i was on it oh
yeah you were oh you were joking
guest driver guy oh really you're a ups
driver yeah he uh i wouldn't invite uh
however it was off to him to my uh to my
party and he kept trying to get invited
that's hilarious
like what the hell i just oh when do you
start shooting such an actor i mean
kevin james
he's phenomenal he's a good stand-up too
and a great guy great great stand up
kevin james is this talented and his
goodness oh my god yes that's not an
accident
um would you start shooting schooled
again august 5th
august 5 buddy you ready chin yes yeah
i was going to say pat knows what's on
it and he's awesome on it too oh dude
have you seen him on uh
uh balls of fury it wasn't tastes good
where he beats him in the pink contest
he comes out with
yeah no i totally forgot that he was oh
he's good in that this guy
there he is he's so he's so
hilarious in that yeah he's great yeah
he's hilarious
all right current events i'll tell you
what buddy you know that 66 percent of
men start to lose their hair by the age
of 35. do you know that that's what
happened to me
i know look at your hair dude and do you
know what if hymns was around you'd have
a full set of hair
you'd have i'm i'm an active customer of
their hair pills better late than never
and they said it's kind of weird
it's kind of working ask me how long it
took me i basically
they had me i had to i talked to a
doctor
online i took a picture of my head yes
filled out a questionnaire and in
five minutes i was done and they sent me
my pills every month
for a fraction of what i was paying for
no middleman dude yeah and no awkward
doctor business right i was paying for a
brand name
and i was paying a lot of money yeah
prescription solutions
backed by science look at brian want
here like can you take oil it's real
stuff i take it i literally take it
for him to connect you products yep
forehands connects you to real doctors
online
which could save you guys hours
completely confidential
discreet all you do is answer a few
quick questions a doctor will review
just like they do with the kid here
and they determine what is right for you
they prescribe you medication to treat
your hair loss
and it's shipped directly to your door
order now
and you guys with crappy here can get
started with him's
complete hair kit for just five dollars
today right now
for five dollars get that thick main
going man see website for full details
and safety information
this could cost hundreds if you went to
the doctor or a pharmacy
somewhere else back in the day the four
or four hymns came along now look at you
now i'm gonna act
like fabio dude oh yeah thank you thank
you i liked it i lied i lied
go to forehands.com fighter that's for
him
f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot-com fighter
for hims.com fighter get your hair right
so i did not feel this because i was in
san jose but did you guys feel the
earthquake
[ __ ] yeah i was in hawaii but was it bad
i was doing [ __ ]
meditation i was
meditating in my [ __ ] did you think
you were like professor x
dude like what is happening place
started to shake
did your dick piece come out i went oh
no and i threw all my clothes and my
shoes
super fast and ran outside like a [ __ ]
yeah they said it's the worst thing you
can do ah
really yeah you never run outside why i
feel like i want to be out in the middle
of the yard nope they say everyone has
that problem
god i love this i love educating wait so
what do i do you go under your table
they say the number one way people die
is they run outside what
yep because everything's falling outside
[ __ ] that's what i want to do is go
outside yeah
so get under my table get on your table
that makes sense
yeah you have to take cover and they're
hoping that these
whole building falls well if your bill's
not that old um
they're they're saying that hopefully
there's a chance it's uh we have a three
percent chance that a bigger earthquake
happens well there's the podcast called
the big one
you know that you're talking about
firing the kid ah [ __ ]
damn vodka yeah
sorry i got excited no i'm talking about
this this podcast called the big one is
dedicated to the
all the science is talking about when it
happens i'm not listening to that it's
going to be crazy
it's not ready it's not oh my god who is
ready
i am my i should be okay wait how high
is your place
are you high at all i live in a 20-story
building seriously
just he lives in like a three-story
building no i live no you know how i'm
on like the uh yeah yeah
when i felt it i was so scared it was it
felt like the entire building was going
to
sway and then crack but that felt like
but they're built yeah
it's so it's a newer building yeah
they're built to sway yeah i said
it's freezing the condo that there's an
earthquake in this sway and i complain
i don't like that no it's the worst
because you have to sway them
tip over of course but i still don't um
but the big one they say it's just a
matter of time right
yeah what does that mean though well
usually when you have a large earthquake
smaller aftershocks follow but the one
that happened
after thursday was actually bigger the
first one was 6.4
and the second one was 7.1 so now people
are saying comes in threes and threes
yeah so we've had
three big ones no we've had three the
three big ones
now there's been little ones but we
can't feel them there's so little
so they said there's a 97 chance of it
not happening a bigger one soon
which is good because we need to release
all that pressure that's been built up
that's what she said
uh so
yeah i guess all you can do is get under
your table
well and stock up on food canned foods
are always good
having some sort of uh power source is
good
so you can cook with like a butane stove
something like that you guys really
you do i've been to your place store
water beans
um i got an arsenal yeah
dude because my ac is out right i was
thinking of uh
basically the apocalypse and my season
swept my ass off
so i have to leave the windows open not
exactly a cool breeze at night over
there
and uh the [ __ ] coyotes man four in
the morning
dude if i had an ak-47 i would
dude they are so loud yep i had a song
bird that used to wake me up at five in
the morning for a long time
and i knew where it was and i would walk
out and i was like
and i and i had a pellet gun yeah kill
him and i go i'm going to kill that
[ __ ] thing and i just couldn't bring
myself to do it did you see it you
couldn't see
what you got to do you know you do do it
like jon jones shoot him right in the
knee
that stupid black leg yo no i'm not that
good a shot and also i
just couldn't i was like a little bird
guessing
all birds have black legs that's not a
racist thing all birds have black legs
name one that doesn't go seagulls no
black
i think i forgot some are like reddish
right spring up arctic flamingos
bring up an arctic goose penguin black
snow goose black well that that's more
of a pink that's a bright
type in why are all uh birds
feet black why are all birds
african-american no i'm not dude i'm not
bringing a racist thing into this i'm
just saying they have black legs and all
they're saying is you take your bb gun
and you shoot them in the black leg says
all birds are black
i'm telling you dude underneath they're
all black
i like crows so much i like a nice crow
myself
frozen good all birds are black
yeah well anyway isn't that cool though
yeah but i was saying b
take your little gun shooting that black
leg yeah
but then he won't be able to do it he's
fine i don't know
like santa's hard to sleep no still
perform yeah but you don't need it dude
just flies away
you should have done that you don't
shoot in this in the gut
no i don't fall no that's the problem
i know that i do those [ __ ] coyotes
though
coyotes are just machine gun that's what
i was thinking about
just go out there with your ak i don't
have an ak
good luck finding them what else you
guys got hopefully the big earthquake
doesn't come if it does chin you're
[ __ ]
cat where do you live uh i live in
burbank you'll be all right but she
might go to
downtown i might move back why i like
burbank man
i like burbank too but i don't know just
looking at like my options
i kind of missed downtown but i feel
like that
i'm thinking of living there with
rose-colored glasses like
it just it's really food food delivery
is
what i want and the food delivery in
burbank's not good
it's okay it's not that great but in
downtown l.a you have so many options
i'm sure you'll be fine i'll be fine
okay
so uh over the weekend disney actually
announced the actress who's gonna be
playing ariel in the little mermaid
movie the live action remake and the
internet
went nuts with a lot of people saying
this isn't good casting because they're
doing it for diversity
and ariel's not black and then another
ariel's a
mermaid you racist exactly that's not
white or black now my aerial was a
ginger okay but times are changing my
spider-man's also not white anymore
and the other thing is with her is did
you see there was a whole campaign
of people saying make sure ariel's white
yes this is a huge campaign
geez by white people people are making
petitions
to have disney change the casting i mean
she could still have red hair
like white people sound frozen i believe
it might be russian bots
i don't know how many white people oh no
there's no there's definitely a campaign
of
morons yeah a lot of people are angry
about this
like the [ __ ] like i posted uh the yeah
well it's one of your current events
we'll get to it
but uh listen she she looks like a great
she's a mermaid
she's a perfect but dude it's a mermaid
art white or black they're just
mermaids well also she's an amazing
singer too
she was she's co-signed by beyonce she's
amazing hallie barry can sing
uh her name is hallie bailey actually
but oh halley baby you're using me too
first oh
racist i'm sorry oh that's hallie bailey
yeah no brendan hold on i need to edit
that i can explain bro
i can explain yeah does that look like
hallelujah
she's gorgeous so [ __ ] it let me see
another picture she's a twin sister as
well so i just
drank into the mic hallie bailey
bro yeah she can be my mermaid any day
so well she's 14.
oh she has never mind let's chill out
like uh oh she's she's
absolutely adorable so yeah
yeah there you go isn't it awesome yeah
so uh
what's the problem people are just mad
that she's black
because well people hate change so
everyone grew up with uh ariel or
redhead all right whatever
she's a [ __ ] mermaid you morons and
she's a cartoon so
they might be they yeah yeah i think
that they're they're [ __ ] people
they're also like protesting that
hollywood is
pushing diversity to the nth degree are
they wrong
you know uh hollywood is a
very good virtue signal yeah it gets old
they always they always go
way way and then they go right this way
and they come back we meet someone in
the middle right listen
this is a mermaid she's universally
beautiful so
i i don't give a [ __ ] but it's also a
mermaid it also sucks because
disney released um the information and
they didn't
they didn't make a big deal out of like
her race or anything it was a lot of
other people just being excited like oh
we have
a black another like black disney
princess and then a lot
it just she looks like a princess period
so she's great
i think the first black like black
princess was princess and the frog
new orleans cartoon or even further back
brandy when she was cinderella
that wasn't a cartoon yeah either way
but that was it was that disney
uh i don't remember if it was disney i
think that's a boo
that girl can also sing she looks like
that and she can sing oh she's so tough
she's
amazing i mean you talk about having it
all that's crazy yeah
all right you win that's called being
undeniable
that you see that is that's called what
i was but she also looks like an ariel
yeah
she looks great exactly i always say if
you want to make it in hollywood that's
that you got to be undeniable that's
what you're competing with
yeah so a 22 year old brooklyn woman
at midnight called the police because
her car was stolen
she wanted the police to come and look
for her car faster than what she thought
they would do
and in order to do that she actually
said that her nephew was in the car
that was stolen to have them come faster
they ended up finding the car a few
hours later just a couple of blocks away
found out that her nephew was never in
the car and she ended up being arrested
listen it's a chrysler pacifica so you
didn't need to do that
if it was a goddamn ferrari i would do
that
the chrysler pacifica we'll find another
here's the thing with that though
like in the er if you ever go to the er
always lie
it's a one lie you can always lie when
they go pain one to ten you go
it's eleven man otherwise because if you
owe four well they
they're gonna put you back in the list
they're gonna deal with pen
yeah they deal with tens nines and
eights so we go i'm like a three man
manual
very cool c in seven hours yeah i even
if
it's nothing i go it's an eleven man i
don't if i'll make it through the night
they get on you right away as as a man i
don't do that but i have
shingles and i did say to him i gotta be
i gotta yes they allow somebody this is
y'all say eleven dude couldn't sleep
every time say eleven if you want if you
want fast service say an eleven yeah
but also don't lie about a chrysler
pacifica because you know what no one
cares
in 2008 crescent pacific 400 000
i'll give you three dollars for that car
and then pay me back
okay so a s starbucks has issued an
apology to the tempe police department
because on july 4th there were six
officers just kind of hanging around
after they paid for their coffee
when a customer told a barista that she
felt uncomfortable with the police
officers being there
the barista then went up to the group
and she actually knew one of the guys by
name because he was a regular
and asked if the group could either
leave
or be out of the customer's eye line
how about we kick that customer the [ __ ]
out oh the customer said i don't feel
safe with cops there
until a like without cops see what
happens until a roving gang comes in and
takes everything you want
that [ __ ] people like this you don't
feel safe then get the [ __ ] out of there
also don't be a [ __ ] yeah yeah you that
oh so the police don't make you feel
like
these people have no idea what's
happening so how about uh so
in retaliation of this black rifle
coffee who i work with
goes all right starbucks wants to kick
out cops [ __ ] them
we're gonna do anyone who buys a bag of
coffee between now and like july
whatever that night anyone who buys a
bag coffee we're going to send a bag of
coffee to these cops yeah
so i posted that one hey help the cops
out blah blah blah
this dumbass i posted on my uh ig page
uh story i said look at look at the dumb
ass of the day this guy goes what about
how dare you
shop promote police they're the enemy
there these should be
yeah and what are you gonna do without
my favorite thing dummy
yeah you [ __ ] you're so dumb and then
i thought maybe this is like uh
underprivileged kid grew up maybe maybe
the cops have picked them
it was a white hippy what a surprise
you're a [ __ ] idiot
you're a [ __ ]
you don't know you need the cops until
you need the cops
the [ __ ] is going on here what's that me
that's a cop uh
you don't know you're you don't the the
idea that that starbucks
starbucks better make it right because
i'm not going to starbucks i'm not going
to starbucks that they make it
and i know it's a franchise and it was
it was obviously this [ __ ] moment
the fact that the barista even like i
would say to that customer well then get
the [ __ ] out of here
because they're police officers and i
like police officers and we need police
officers
and they have a hard job so go [ __ ]
yourself that makes me so mad
starbucks what
i feel like tempe should uh protest
that starbucks what's the address that
starbucks then again it might have been
a dumb
barista who didn't know better who was
trying to trying to broke her piece here
but i think that customer is a piece of
[ __ ] and i hope they hear it
and uh you know go [ __ ] yourself yeah
[ __ ] yourself when you're a victim of
crime and you have to call the cops
they'll show up they'll show up they'll
do their job for you they'll protect you
anyway because that's not going to come
fast but i've had some problems then i
come fast but they're still going to
come
yeah it's a hard job being a cop oh yeah
[ __ ] hard job
very tough and it makes it way worse for
morale and everything else when you get
kicked out of a [ __ ] coffee shop on
4th of july
when you're trying to keep the peace so
it's
i i these are the mice starbucks
starbucks headquarters probably like oh
god what the [ __ ] also
you know the barista yeah
the guests felt uncomfortable or unsafe
i
you [ __ ] oh i wonder what the guests
though i know what that guest looks like
uh well i guarantee probably super white
lady like a lady a white gal a white gal
with
[ __ ] dreads and and uh i hate america
or something like that
i'm a global citizen or some [ __ ] yeah
they suck
like you know what else without with a
[ __ ]
i don't get into it all right these
[ __ ] idiots
this is i think this is a really sad
story so some guy
tried to rob one of those firework
stands and then during the time of the
robbery
while he was getting the money he put
his gun down for a second
yeah so the employee one of the
employees grabbed it and shot him in the
face
yeah there you go buddy was robbing the
place yeah
well that's what happened i'm guessing
he's super and you pour them down
because you make a lot of bad choices
one is
to rob a store the to put your gun down
here's the
thing full of batteries here's the thing
though yeah you're robbing a
firework stand yeah the guy working the
firework stand
did you have to shoot him in the face
over fireworks well i think he probably
the guy had a gun so you think you might
get killed did you shoot him in the face
did you not say get the fight he doesn't
panic he probably panicked and just shot
he's distraught now too obviously
you don't i don't need you to defend the
black cats by any means necessary i
don't need to shoot the guy in the face
for m80s
i think he probably just grabbed it and
you know when somebody's got a gun yeah
and they're robbing him
no he's well they they don't have an
idea on him still and he's in critical
condition the loss i heard
yeah i mean in this situation people get
shot all the time that was 19. that's
terrible
but you know then again if you're going
to rob a store
you're you could get shot by the cops
the guy yeah that's that's right you pay
in the price you pay yeah
but i'm sure the guy's upset but the
guy's also kind of a badass he thought
quickly
who knows this guy might have shot him
all so he didn't you never know there's
a gun involved
firecrackers are hard for me life and
death you point a gun at me life and
death you freak out if you saw
a gun oh for sure yeah for sure i get it
man
all right we were talking about this guy
not too long ago i can't believe this
happened
this billionaire guy that would dated el
ellen norgen
remember tiger woods x oh remember that
billionaire guy you'll see him right
here
this guy oh you just talked about we
were talking about creepy looks weren't
we
he just died in a helicopter accident
with his daughter yeah and what happened
was
i guess they were doing his birthday
party in the bahamas and the daughter
fell sick
so they were trying to get her to a
hospital so they took a helicopter and
it crashed almost immediately the
helicopter did yeah
they all died they're still
investigating it
but this yeah and that's his daughter
unfortunately passed away
the one on the right the left i think
that's terrible man
wow what a bummer she was 21 yeah and
that guy was a billionaire
worth 1.8 billion who gets that money
the
the tiger's wife mexicans well they
broke up they're just dating
ball what they were just dating and they
broke up
that's tough 60 year old client
dude helicopter like again that's your
one thing my girl went oh you want to go
on a helicopter in hawaii no
pros and cons pros i see some scenic
[ __ ]
mountains of hawaii which i can see on
the internet cons we crash and die
well you know my my wife and i when we
when my daughter was really young
we were going to do an air they wanted
to just do a hot air balloon thing oh no
it's like
no i'm not doing that because not one of
us can go man you mean go
10 000 feet in the air no hope in a
basket
in a picnic basket well a hard note from
me hard no
why oh because you can hang over the
side hard no well no i get a drone and
that's right where congo for a
sightseeing thing
that'll be another no uh you want to
climb mount everest
absolutely not no pros and cons dude
too many things can go wrong yep those
balloons burn up too
have you seen those yeah it's awful it's
on fire in the helicopter
no panama with a bunch of others this is
yeah yeah no like
yeah i don't know yeah who knows no you
know what i'm saying it all depends yeah
i'm there
what what what else you got
this is some crazy turbulence in this
airplane oh boy
i saw this it's in sweden right oh this
really spills coffee over
i read something about sweda sweden but
then the swedish
sweden a flight attendant just check her
out and but
the coffee just went everywhere yeah
people got burned from the coffee but
this is the worst turbulence i've seen
[Music]
[Applause]
god that's scary lasts up to 10 minutes
that's a lifetime yeah and she's praying
right there oh [ __ ] yeah i cannot stand
turbulence
i don't know how these guys even got
through this dude i've done some praying
myself when the flight was a little
rocky oh dear god
don't planes usually not crash though
from turbulence oh never
and here's the other thing that no one's
ever crashed from turbulence planes only
really crash
from takeoff or landing they never crash
from turbulence
wings can literally like fold like a
goddamn pretzel up in
like this that's what they're built for
whenever they crash it's either pilot
air like going down
or you know but never from like just the
brain
you gotta break it yeah you gotta just
make sure pour out all your [ __ ] hops
now hold on before i say that's 100
percent bro science but i'm almost
my father my father's a pilot will tell
you that yeah i'm telling you i'm always
part of my father told me that's why i
don't get nervous
crashing and landing like taking off and
landing is the most dangerous times
in the air it's all good baby let's just
kill yourself
yeah have you seen the ones when they
land they land like because of the wind
and it almost lands sideways but then
they
the tires that's called sheer sheer
winds or [ __ ] something like that you
know that's crazy
uh dragons can crash your plane
sometimes that's a problem dragons will
get what else she got
uh this guy you can't see his face here
but he was uh impersonating a police
officer and ended up pulling over a
sheriff's deputy
so he had those things built in his car
like it looked like a it was a black car
had the lights had us
had like a flashing lights and siren on
it tight move
why was he this guy oh well clearly he
just told he was like telling the guy to
slow down
and the cop was like uh where's your
credentials
he goes uh it's at the station i'll you
know drive with you and i'll show it and
then you try to leave and they call 911.
just because he wanted to pretend that
he was a cop he was bored he just said
slow down that was his main thing he's
like my buddies
starts fires that this is my buddy's a
lawyer for this kid who starts fires all
the time
and then dresses up like a fireman and
and move and
waves the cars away from the fire
hilarious he's hiding he's
weird 15 times i go uh do you keep
defending him he keeps getting him off
basically he goes i go he's a sociopath
he goes he he is he just enjoys watching
you are so weird
get that guy in in jail he dresses up
like a fireman and waves cars
and they they go hey you come here you
do this again
people are so strange he's been doing it
since he was like 11.
all right did you guys hear about that
70 year old guy that uh who was
accused of cheating on a marathon he
broke a record
yeah he was like there's a doctor from
how to hear about this he's a retired
doctor and he
he loved doing marathons and then some
private investigator found out that
he was doing course course cutting oh so
he's like taking shortcuts yeah and he
was waiting
he just cut across yeah so this
investigator found out he was doing it
they caught him on camera doing some
stuff he still
said he was innocent but the guy said
the guy that was accused of cheating
said he was innocent but the guy was
like no
he had a record time for someone in his
age group so yeah he definitely was
coarse cutting
later on this was last week they found
him dead in the l.a river yeah like
recently god killed himself
that's what they're thinking his family
is saying that saying that uh he had a
heart condition
but the investigation is about him
possibly committing suicide oh man
a seven-year-old marathon runner
fighting a cheating scandal
was found dead in a river in california
officials found dr
frank meza thursday under a bridge in
the los angeles river
now he won the la marathon two months
ago oh that's a shame man
threw out his score recently after
that's a shame kind of just
cutting in yeah i mean just he
cheated in a marathon though it's a
marathon
man you got you're kind of like uh
you're kind of feeling for a lot of
people your
your heart's a little big hawaii's
expanded your heart a little bit dude oh
dude
you're feeling bad for cheating uh
marathon guys and for
firecracker robbers you wanna good for
you
so like your heart's big dude thank you
first of all thank you for
having such a big heart you're welcome
yeah you're welcome
you're welcome dude that's him there he
looks like that's his uh kids they're
all like doctors too that's his
there's him on the writer that's his kid
that's his son who's a dog they look
identical they look very much alike
um one last one on a high note
hey to get any more people dying this is
mariah carey she's got a little cat
hits on this song bird tits on this song
right check it out how would you knock
the cap off i want to kick this i got a
wheel kick
that was real that was really hard hold
on
do it again yeah
dude i'd much prefer them with their
string that was really funny i don't
know you couldn't see it they did it
well
definitely a string that was really two
grown men
what's in our voice pretty crazy right
hold on one more time
let's see if you can see it even
yeah you see the bottle move because
they're pulling it i know but still you
can't see it hey
though you know i don't know mariah's
voice
that is pretty much dude she's a she's a
baddie i heard she's a nightmare to deal
with
yeah she's you know about us you know
it's not a nightmare to deal with me and
spakan
this weekend 11 12-13 get your [ __ ]
tickets
and then san francisco i'll be at cobb's
the 19th and the 20th
ha can't wait ha can't wait san
francisco i'm in cincinnati this week
friday saturday
cincy with the boys assan and derrick
poston bubba baba
bringing that l.a comedy deo city
cincinnati
we're uh
the funny bone cincinnati friday and
saturday two shows friday
two shows saturday next week i'm in indy
your favorite place
brian brian said the place sucks but i'm
still coming indie next weekend
thursday friday saturday i don't think
it's time i'm just kidding you did say
it sucks so if you've never been
indeed helium thursday friday saturday
is next week
nashville zany's for august first to the
third those tickets are almost sold out
and then portland just got announced
that's august 15th to 17th
but get your tickets now for this
weekend cincinnati or friday saturday
tfackk.com for brian and myself yeah is
that it dude yeah you're going to like
indianapolis actually
you're going to like it yeah you said it
was awful no i did not say that i didn't
understand i
didn't have a market yeah you're mad uh
yeah so
uh my special complicated apes streaming
live on amazon
check it out go see it man it's killing
on amazon yep and then showtime just
released my hulk hogan bit
so you can see it if you haven't seen
the special good go get you the tasty
hulk hogan
sexy bit it's on uh below the belt
youtube page
but for tickets for brian and myself
tvk.com
this leviathan kid we're out